what sound do you like the [ __ ]
[Music]
so you guys know about King Charles
right he's the new guy he got all the
ribbons and [ __ ] that's him he's the new
king England you know about that do you
know all right did you know Elizabeth
died you know I sure do all right there
you go you're up to speed you're up to
speed too that's all we needed to know
that's it sick all right we're just
trying to ride sir I always get reminded
of [ __ ] like this because you know when
you look at historical like busts you're
like there's the ugliest [ __ ]
I've ever seen right and they're like
I've never even seen these type of
people in person and then you see a
picture of King Charles they're like oh
you're gonna be a future ugly bust a
future ugly bus that's such a good point
Who's the Phillip guy Prince Philip
Prince Philip dude he looked like the
Crypt Keeper is it Andrew your favorite
Andrew's my favorite Prince Andrews
Prince Andrew's my favorite because he's
like he's a he's like a Playboy you know
like yeah yeah
he's like he's bombing bro he's cool wow
he's cool and sometimes he wears his
tiles Ty's all [ __ ] up just because
you don't care love that he's he reminds
me like Tony Stark hashtag reinstate
fellow Andrew yeah he's he's the Playboy
he's The Playboy of the whole uh of the
family is it true that they're all
inbred what's the deal with that yeah
I keep I keep hearing this narrative not
for real I keep hearing this narrative
about how everyone in the world family
is immigrant so like is that true or is
it 100 True is this all Nick day
I'm just trying to feed off Anthony just
kill it with your time with your type 10
dude I'm a spectator bro I'm trying to
hear the news I like it so the news is
that King Charles is gonna be an ugly
bus
Studies have shown
he hired a piper to wake him up every
morning by playing bagpipes outside his
window at 9am every single day since he
became king immediately becoming king
that's the British version of The Coming
to America intro right how extra is that
great for the guy he's like I'm booked
for her good every morning good for him
but also great for the tax dollars that
are big at least it's [ __ ] bagpipes
because otherwise where the [ __ ] else is
this guy gonna play that's true I'd
rather get like Kenny G or something
dude Kenny G to wake you up yeah yeah kg
would be sick kid you outside like
[Music]
you know you're popping a morning boner
to that one I mean that's more of a go
to sleep thing right I saw I was
watching the this is off topic but I was
watching the uh the pranks that you did
on the kids that open up Christmas gifts
and one of the kids got a Kenny G
[ __ ] CD and he was like he was like
he was super bummed and then later they
interviewed him and he goes well I
looked him up and he's he's a good
singer so I'm really happy now
the kids were trying to justify all this
[ __ ] I gave him it was so fun it was
so fun
child like Wonder total rationalizations
like like just like desperation coping
yeah Kenny G's so [ __ ] dope and I
hate that like at an early age like
[ __ ] elitist musicians made me think
he was like such a hack yeah he's sick
he's [ __ ] good I get that jazz
[ __ ] people hate him like I get it
but I don't get that yeah starving
artist exactly that's probably the only
reason why well it's because like as a
like as someone that's supposed to be
representing smooth jazz to like the
general public what he's doing is not
really at the level of what Jazz already
has been like it's easy [ __ ] oh is that
what it is but it's digestible but it's
sexy Jazz sounds like noise it's good
you know but it's that's that's
equivalent to like an opera singer
ripping on Taylor Swift and going that's
[ __ ] that's it only three octaves
like you know like it's she's only got
three octaves I don't know I don't know
what I'm saying well but all I know is
that I liked Kenny G and I was shamed
for it I just love the idea of Bart like
at a museum just being disgusting
with all these busts he's walking he's
like
he's like why am I here I'm like God
damn bro and you think it's the fault of
the artist at first you're like oh they
just suck at making people but then you
realize I want to see that bus those
eyebrows like this way I think it's the
inbreeding that why it's the random
shapes of the face oh really or because
there is a look to them where you're
just like they're just not
typically like George Washington they're
not good looking George Washington has a
perfect protractor forehead yeah yeah
road trip yeah it's a [ __ ] Hollywood
Bowl right there and then he has a
[ __ ] I don't know some Doritos chip
knows I don't know anyone that looks
like that in real life we don't know we
don't know if the guy who was like doing
his portrait back in the day was doing
it all realism and then he was like no
no no no you got to fix that yeah and
then you watch Hamilton and he's like a
total different race yeah which one is
it dude which one is it that's a good
point anybody watch holy moly by the way
I think they're all but that's it what
the [ __ ] is that
yeah I Googled George Washington he
looks like he goes
and when he breathes out of chicks yeah
I can hear his nose briefing he's the
guy that comes up and goes the Museum's
now closed he can breathe underwater
just fine yeah yeah exactly you can
[ __ ] tip that thing out so what's the
article about can I King Charles King
Charles hire a piper bro that's what it
was do you think
I forgot do you think the bad pipes are
a pleasant sound to him or a you know
some people like pleasant sounds they
want like
you know what's funny is I I really like
the sound but only in the context of
when there's like a funeral because it's
pretty [ __ ] tragic because you got
lots of funerals going on because you
know yeah and they're all [ __ ] Irish
based isn't that Scottish I don't know
but which sound do you like the [ __ ]
[Music]
when you wake up in the morning that's
that's what you want to hear I mean it's
an emotional noise okay
most people have that sound right this
one and I hate it
I hate it yeah I thought that was my
phone
I commentate it too much with like
waking up yeah it's attached to going oh
[ __ ] instant drama it's traumatizing
yeah what do you guys have as your alarm
tones bat [ __ ] that one because it
freaks me out yeah you're like oh [ __ ]
gotta wake up yeah what do you have yeah
what do you have I think my mom just
wakes up you know my most recent one
might be a song let me check I you know
what's funny is I tried to put a song I
liked and then it just made me associate
the stress of that song and it ruined
the song I used to have Hit Me With Your
Best Shot no if I ruined then I was like
[ __ ] that song man you should do uh
no that took me too long to even
recognize it oh this is one of my more
recent songs
oh this is Ryan's song oh this isn't
poison this is oh no it's not because it
makes you like you wake up and you feel
good already
[Music]
yeah
that was just Bruno Mars one right yeah
Bruno Mars
you wake up to a song that you like and
you're just gonna like Groove in your
bed and you just go back to sleep
that could happen too you're late but
you're just going okay you just never
arrive my alarm's my cat that's what it
is I was like what is my alarm recording
of your cat no my my alarm is my cat 6
30 every morning on the dot oh your cat
just always knows to always knows it's
like time to eat [ __ ] dude our
cat does that to Nikki it's [ __ ]
hilarious it like bites your [ __ ]
head off in the morning yeah
crazy but like on the dot 6 30 it
doesn't it doesn't matter it's like no
[ __ ] it's Sunday like no you don't get
throw a pillow at it
I had plenty of those I'm not even on
the bed I'm on the floor covering that's
right
there's pillows falling off the bed on
me in the middle of night too it's your
cat actually doing to physically like
wake you up literally uh going like this
like
oh that's sight like when they go like
they jab just like oh it's really soft
and it doesn't have the paws out or
anything but it's still very like clear
like does your cat ever do that to Nina
or is it just you Dustin Nina too but uh
I think like Nina like really wants me
to feed them in the morning so he's
starting to get used to just me but like
he used to [ __ ] so is Morpheus just
the guy he always used to [ __ ] bite
me in his hair and pull at it oh [ __ ]
right you know what I'm talking about
like and it [ __ ] will hurt when he
bites Nikki's nose or cat why do you
think he's no but you ever see that that
scene in like Lion King when like
[ __ ] Sim is trying to wake up his dad
and like bites his ear and pulls him
over like it's you know it's very
playful that [ __ ] still hurts have you
ever tried pre-feeding it so you can
sleep in a little bit more does that
work we feed at like midnight still as
well give them like a midnight snack
it's just part of the things they get so
used to routine as well you know what I
mean and then there are days like
sometimes when Nina's like not looking
on like Saturday nights because I know I
want to wake up later on Sunday I'll be
like feeding them double at midnight you
know what I mean watch you just do that
sometimes it works it'll slow them down
like 30 more minutes yeah exactly dude I
think they love the routine would you
like it if your cat went next to your
ear instead of batting you it just went
DOMA
to answer the question would you like
that yeah that'd be crazy and talk to
you sometimes our cat climbs behind if
it's like she's really been sleeping in
he climbs like under her [ __ ] head
and starts picking her up with his body
like craning his neck up it's hilarious
which one Franklin the gray one yeah
love Franklin yeah he's the best but
it's like
like that's my alarm clock if anything
it's just Nikki going oh [ __ ] she's like
biting her time to wake up he'll even
like wake up all startled every morning
like like she has like sometimes elastic
hair bands on or whatever he'll [ __ ]
bite and snap that yeah oh wow that's
[ __ ] genius he doesn't like
accessories oh like like we'll bite it
to like yes wow that's good that is
tight whatever tortures her awake he'll
do that's good just to get food always
leaves you alone to feed the cats
because he doesn't even really eat he
actually just wants like his brother and
now his brother and sister fed he just
wants to make sure they get fed he like
kind of sits there while they all eat
and he's like okay good how cool it's
hilarious yeah he's a little general
[Music]
foreign